now call me crazy right I think this is
a bit of a double standard that we have
in society that we let women get away
with this stuff but if a man does it
it's the end of the world now some
people will say well Pearl cheating and
seeking attention from men is not the
same thing okay well then you don't
believe in my premise then you know fine
but I think I think it's very similar
because attention women what was our
mating strategy get the best attention
that we could get from the highest value
you got what was men's mating strategy
screw as many people as possible so when
we get married we're supposed to
compromise on our mating strategies I'll
stop looking for better and better and
better